January 17 16 having failed to find gold
in Florida and still hoping to return to
Maria a successful man Sam Bellamy had
made his way to the thriving ports of
the Caribbean now his new career as a
pirate was well underway
the first time we hear about Sam Bellamy
in terms of being active pirate is when
he joins a small pirate fleet under the
command of Benjamin hornigold
then was an old Buccaneer who had been
attacking the Spanish for years and knew
everything there was to know about high
seas robbery
Bellamy rose rapidly through the ranks
of benjamin hornigold's crew but there
was a problem
hornigold was happy to plunder foreign
ships but refused to touch those from
his native country Britain he wanted to
limit his attacks to the ones he'd been
attacking during the old war to Spanish
and the French hornigold's policy meant
that over half the ships they came
across were out of bounds Sam Bellamy
had no truck with us they were
new-school pirates if they saw a ship
and this old was flying a Union flag
they would attack it regardless
Bellamy decided to challenge horn gold
for the captaincy of his ship the crew
would make the choice amazingly for a
band of men with a reputation for
violence and brutality pirates elected
their captains by democratic vote not
only did Pirates elect their captains
but every decision on board a pirate
ship was put to the vote every man could
have his say in the early 18th century
this was radical if not revolutionary
back on land society was divided between
rich and poor and such equality was
unheard of I think you could say that
life on board the pirate ship was very
democratic you know there obviously had
to be some discipline because you
couldn't run a ship but there seems to
have been great equality and a
recognition of equality between everyone
on board from the captain downwards
there were no top dogs in that sense
Bellamy challenged hornigold and one
within a year of joining the Pirates the
new recruit had al stood his former
mentor in a bloodless coup and taken
command himself say I was able to talk
the rest of the crew into voting out
hornigold as captain in voting himself
in his commander of the pirate fleet and
it's at that time his career really
takes off
the crew members pledged their
allegiance to the new captain Sam
Bellamy Bellamy was in his late 20s but
what he lacked in experience he made up
for in charisma and command and his
pirate career was under full sail like
Sam was certainly a character one of his
titles was the Prince of pirates because
he was supposed to be very magnanimous
towards his prisoners unusual among a
group of people who would as soon kill
them and toss them overboard true to his
reputation for generosity
Bellamy allowed the ousted pirate
captain hornigold to leave unharmed he
was lucky pirate captains of the time
were rarely so high-minded towards their
captives we prata made you play about
pirates they were a nasty lot really
they were out to rob people with
violence as fast and as quickly as
possible which is why why they used
torture a lot they did basic things like
cutting off ears and noses that happened
quite a lot they would hang people up in
the rigging and use them for target
practice with knives and muskets that
the nastiest one of all was the in
trailer one where they slit you open
grabbed hold of your entrails tied it
onto a stick and then made you dance
until all your entrails came out and
presumably at one point you simply
collapsed and died
marooning leaving a prisoner behind on
an uninhabited island was another
favorite punishment in fact it proves so
popular that the pirate captains of the
Golden Age were referred to as marinas
but the most famous of all pirate
punishments was to force prisoners to
walk the plank far from being the
invention of 20th century movie
directors there are historical records
suggesting pirate captains made their
captives walk the plank even with
cannonballs tied to their feet but
Bellamy was a different kind of pirate
captain he was fair-minded and
considered all his crew to be part of a
brutal Brotherhood
the Pirates lived and died by their own
set of rules
a pirate code of conduct which they
would swear to obey it would vary from
ship to ship and it would be a sort of
loose code of rules for the Pirates they
were things like you must keep your
weapons clean any pirate who deserts his
post in battle shall be marooned any
pirate who steals from the common chest
shall be executed as a whole lot of them
no women to be allowed on board so on
and so forth
[Music]